This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the year 1623, Christian IV, king of Denmark and Norway, built a long series of moats and ramparts just across from central Copenhagen, on the eastern edge of the city's harbor. For much of the 17th century, the fortification protected the city from Swedish invasion. In the early 19th century, the Danish government added artillery barracks, and in the 19th century, the fortification protected the city from Swedish invasion. In the early 19th century, the Danish government added artillery barracks. And in the 20th century, they filled in the surrounding swamps to make room for a modern military base, even as the rest of Copenhagen grew around it. That is, until 1971, when the sprawling fortress in the center of the city transformed into something else entirely.
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。1623年，丹麦兼挪威国王克里斯蒂安四世（Christian IV）在哥本哈根市中心对面、该市港口的东缘，建造了一系列长长的护城河和壁垒。在17世纪的大部分时间里，这处防御工事保护着该市免受瑞典的入侵。在19世纪初，丹麦政府增建了炮兵军营，而在19世纪，这处防御工事保护着该市免受瑞典的入侵。在19世纪初，丹麦政府增建了炮兵军营。到了20世纪，他们填平了周边的沼泽，为现代军事基地腾出空间，尽管哥本哈根的其他地方在它周围不断发展。直到1971年，这座位于城市中心的庞大堡垒彻底变成了另一种完全不同的东西。
And he started off with the kids who had, of course, been wondering what goes on in there. They saw the soldiers coming in and out, they heard the military music, but they were never allowed to go in there. John Bang Carlsen was in his early 20s when he moved to Copenhagen from his conservative home in the Danish countryside. And he says the symbolism of a military base in the heart of the country's capital was not lost on him and his friends. As reporter Scott Gurion.
他最初接触的是那些当然一直想知道里面究竟发生了什么的孩子们。他们看到士兵进进出出，听到军乐队的音乐，但他们从来不被允许进去。约翰·邦·卡尔森（John Bang Carlsen）20岁出头时，从丹麦乡村保守的家乡搬到了哥本哈根。他说，该国首都中心的军事基地的象征意义，他和朋友们都心知肚明。记者斯科特·古里安（Scott Gurion）报道。
The base's walls represented authority, repression, pretty much everything Denmark's younger generation had come to Copenhagen to escape. But in 1971, the Danish Defense Ministry decided they no longer needed the base and they closed it for good. So suddenly one morning we see all the soldiers marching out of there, you know, see all the vehicles leave, the military vehicles leave, and they don't close the door. John speaking figuratively, technically the doors were locked, but people living nearby realized they could break in and no one would stop them. Somehow the army, the big, big father figure had kind of died in our middle, in the middle of the city, right?
基地的围墙代表着权威、镇压，几乎是丹麦年轻一代来到哥本哈根想要逃离的一切。但在1971年，丹麦国防部决定不再需要这个基地，并将其永久关闭。所以突然在某个早晨，我们看到所有的士兵从里面列队撤出，你知道的，看到所有的车辆离开，军车离开，而且他们没有关门。约翰用的是比喻，严格来说门是锁着的，但住在附近的居民意识到他们可以闯进去，而且没人会阻止他们。不知怎的，军队这个巨大无比的大家长形象，在我们中间、在这座城市中央消亡了，对吧？
And we could just crawl over the walls. And like two weeks before we would have been shot if we did the same thing. Like any young person who comes across an abandoned, boarded up property, John was curious to explore. The first evening he climbed over the barbed wire walls, the interior of the base was dark. He couldn't see much other than the broken glass from kids who had already vandalized the former barracks. But as the sun rose, it became clear to John just what he and the other trespassers had on their hands. This was not some cramped, depressing concrete jungle. Instead, the world within the fortress's walls was almost rural.
我们只需爬过围墙就行了。而在仅仅两周前，如果我们做同样的事，就会被枪杀。就像任何偶然发现废弃、被木板封住房产的年轻人一样，约翰对探索充满好奇。第一天傍晚，当他翻过带刺的铁丝网围墙时，基地内部一片漆黑。除了那些已经破坏了前军营的熊孩子留下的碎玻璃外，他看不清太多东西。但随着太阳升起，约翰终于看清了他和其他闯入者手里究竟得到了什么。这里绝不是什么逼仄、令人沮丧的混凝土丛林。相反，堡垒围墙内的世界几乎带着田园风情。
At 85 acres, the base contained vast green spaces, hills, patches of forest. There was even a lake with the hulking shapes of empty stables and ammunition depots scattered in charming arrangements around the landscape. And the trespassers wasted no time making themselves at home. And whatever we wanted to do, we were free to do it. We could snap up whatever house if we wanted 2,000 square meters to live on, we could do that.
占地85英亩的基地拥有广阔的绿地、山丘和零星的森林。甚至还有一个湖泊，湖畔景观周围错落有致地散落着废弃马厩和军火库的庞大轮廓。闯入者毫不犹豫地把这里当成了自己的家。任何我们想做的事，我们都可以自由去做。如果我们想要2000平方米的房子来居住，我们可以随心所欲地霸占任何一栋房子。
And where I finally ended up was a beautiful, beautiful old farm, you know, wonderful reflection of beautiful trees, you know, around the lake. And the only thing that reminded you of the city was you could hear the police sirens. But visually, it was like paradise somehow. John and the other trespassers ended up squatting in various buildings throughout the base, and as word spread, the abandoned compound quickly became a haven for the unwanted, the abused, and the dispossessed. A lot of the kids that came there were from very poor backgrounds, you know, runaways from
我最终落脚的地方是一座美丽绝伦的老农庄，你知道的，湖水周围倒映着美丽的树木，美不胜收。唯一能让你想起这座城市的是你能听到警笛声。但在视觉上，这里某种程度上就像是天堂。约翰和其他闯入者最终在基地各处的建筑里非法占地居住，随着消息传开，这个废弃的园区迅速成为了不被需要者、受虐者和被剥夺者的避难所。来到那里的许多孩子都出身非常贫困的家庭，你知道的，他们是
being mistreated sexually, or people who came out of jail and had nowhere to go, people who otherwise would be put into institutions. So suddenly this corpse of a military army base was beginning to get to resurrect, but resurrect as something which was in total discord with what it originally was meant to be. And it was during their first few weeks that the ragtag group of squatters So, this accord with what it originally was meant to be. And it was during their first few weeks that the ragtag group of squatters decided to get organized. They declared the base a, quote, politically autonomous anarchist zone, or in plainer English,
遭受性虐待的离家出走者，或是刚出狱无处可去的人，本会被送进收容所的人。因此，这个形同尸体的军队基地突然开始复活，但这种复活却与它最初的设立初衷完全背道而驰。正是在最初的几个星期里，这群乌合之众般的占地者——所以，这与它最初的设立初衷完全背道而驰。正是在最初的几个星期里，这群乌合之众般的占地者决定组织起来。他们宣布该基地为一个“政治自治的无政府主义区”，用更通俗的话来说，
a commune. Only this commune would become far larger and more consequential than anyone outside could have imagined. Like many other communes, the founders wanted the new world they made within the walls to be as free as possible from all the old world's rules and customs and hierarchies. We suddenly had a chance to kind of say, okay, we don't know what happens, we don't know anything, we have to create our own society." And it was a little like a beautiful blank piece of paper and you could start writing a new story, right?
就是一个公社。只是这个公社将变得比外面任何人想象的都要庞大得多、影响深远得多。就像许多其他公社一样，创始人希望他们在围墙内创造的新世界能够尽可能地摆脱所有旧世界的规则、习俗和等级制度。我们突然有了一个机会可以说：“好吧，我们不知道会发生什么，我们什么也不知道，我们必须建立我们自己的社会。”这有点像一张美丽的白纸，你可以开始书写一段新的历史，对吧？
They drew up a mission statement according to which the goal of the commune was, quote, to create a self-governing society whereby each and every individual holds themselves responsible for the well-being of the entire community. They also settled on a name, taking a cue from the surrounding Christians Harbor neighborhood. holds themselves responsible for the well-being of the entire community. They also settled on a name, taking a cue from the surrounding Christians Harbor neighborhood. They called their community Christiania. But unlike a lot of other idealistic communities of the 60s and 70s, Christiania is still around, and in many ways it has achieved the dreams of its founders.
他们起草了一份使命宣言，根据该宣言，公社的目标是：“建立一个自治社会，使每一个个人都对整个社区的福祉承担责任。”他们还根据周边的克里斯蒂安港（Christians Harbor）社区定了一个名字。使每一个个人都对整个社区的福祉承担责任。他们还根据周边的克里斯蒂安港社区定了一个名字。他们将自己的社区命名为克里斯蒂安尼亚（Christiania）。但与60和70年代许多其他理想主义社区不同，克里斯蒂安尼亚至今犹存，并在许多方面实现了其创始人的梦想。
Today it's one of the longest-lasting and most celebrated communes in the world, and a magnet for people searching for alternative ways of living, existing both side by side and within a major European city. But in recent years, Christiania's residents have faced an increasing number of threats that have raised tough questions about the limits of autonomy, about how much individual freedom might be too much, and whether to hold onto tradition or change with a changing world. And now, people both inside and outside Christiania's walls are wondering how much longer this utopian
如今，它是世界上存在时间最久、最受赞誉的公社之一，也是吸引人们寻找替代生活方式的磁石，它与一个欧洲大城市并存并在其内部存在着。但在近年来，克里斯蒂安尼亚的居民面临着越来越多的威胁，这些威胁引发了关于自治极限的尖锐问题——关于多少个人自由可能算太多，以及是该坚守传统还是随不断变化的世界而改变。现在，克里斯蒂安尼亚围墙内外的人们都在想，这个乌托邦式的
experiment can ultimately last. Christiania, of course, people moved in to find a place to live, but people very definitely moved into Christianity to be part of making a city that was based on other ideas than the rest of society. This is Ole Lug-Andersen, another early Christiania resident. Ole arrived in the late 1970s, and he described to me what the scene was like after John and the other squatters settled in. Christianity was tough to move into. Two thirds of Christianity had no infrastructure at all.
实验究竟还能持续多久。在克里斯蒂安尼亚，人们搬进来当然是为了找个地方住，但人们搬进克里斯蒂安尼亚绝对是为了参与打造一个基于不同于其余社会理念的城市。这是奥勒·卢格-安德森（Ole Lug-Andersen），另一位早期的克里斯蒂安尼亚居民。奥勒于20世纪70年代末抵达这里，他向我描述了约翰和其他占地者定居后的情景。搬进克里斯蒂安尼亚非常艰难。克里斯蒂安尼亚三分之二的地方完全没有基础设施。
In other words, they might have had all those big old buildings and the basic shelter they needed, but very little else. You had to make heating systems yourself. You had to work with the sewage and electricity and water supply. So it was like moving into the wild west in the 1970s. And so the communes' residents got to work. They adapted the existing structures, building fantastical homes out of recycled
换句话说，他们可能拥有所有那些高大的老建筑和所需的 基本庇护所，但除此之外几乎一无所有。你必须自己搭建供暖系统。你必须处理污水、电力和供水问题。所以这就像是在20世纪70年代搬进狂野西部一样。于是公社居民开始动手干活。他们改造现有结构，用回收的
objects, and filling them with amazing art. They turned a former stable into a church, and transformed a military horse-riding arena into a concert hall. This is Christiania, a community of a thousand hippies and assorted dogs. There are small businesses, a factory that makes customized bicycles, a women's blacksmith shop completely surrounded by Copenhagen's old city. Christiania wasn't totally cut off from the outside world. Its residents would engage in commerce and come and go into the rest of the city.
物品建造了奇幻的房屋，并用惊艳的艺术品将其填满。他们把一座前马厩改造成了一座教堂，并将一个军事骑马场改成了音乐厅。这里是克里斯蒂安尼亚，一个由一千名嬉皮士和各种狗狗组成的社区。这里有小企业、一家制造定制自行车的工厂，以及一个完全被哥本哈根老城包围的女性铁匠铺。克里斯蒂安尼亚并没有完全与世隔绝。它的居民会从事商业活动，并在城市其他地方进进出出。
But inside the walls, the community collected its own trash and recycling, operated its own kindergarten, and even had its own newspaper and marching band. Aside from a small shared maintenance fee, residents paid no rent. No one owned their home. And when they moved out, there was nothing to sell. There were no building or zoning codes. There were also no laws. The only rules were no private ownership of land or housing, no weapons or violence, and no vehicles. Otherwise, people in Christiania were pretty much free to do whatever they wanted, play rock music in the streets, do drugs, sell drugs, wear their hair long or shave it off,
但在围墙内，社区收集自己的垃圾和回收物，经营自己的幼儿园，甚至拥有自己的报纸和军乐队。除了少量的共享维护费外，居民不付房租。没有人拥有自己的家。当他们搬走时，也没有什么可卖的。这里没有建筑或区划规范。这里也没有法律。唯一的规则是：不得对土地或房屋进行私有化，不得拥有武器或暴力，不得使用车辆。除此之外，克里斯蒂安尼亚的人们几乎可以自由地做任何他们想做的事：在街上弹奏摇滚乐、吸毒、贩毒、留长发或把头发剃光，
love members of the same sex or a different race. All the things, in other words, that were still dangerous or impossible in the world outside its gates. John told me about a woman who spent her days roller-skating around naked, In other words, that were still dangerous or impossible in the world outside its gates. John told me about a woman who spent her days roller skating around naked and even a guy who kept a pet bear that he fed beer. It always looked as slightly drunk. It was big. It was rather big.
爱上同性或不同种族的人。换句话说，所有在它大门外的世界里仍然危险或不可能做到的事情。约翰跟我讲过一个女人，她整天光着身子踩着旱冰鞋四处闲逛，换句话说，所有在它大门外的世界里仍然危险或不可能做到的事情。约翰跟我讲过一个女人，她整天光着身子踩着旱冰鞋四处闲逛，甚至还有一个家伙养了一只宠物熊，用啤酒喂它。它看起来总是有点醉醺醺的。它很大。相当大。
How did he end up with a bear? I have no idea. I don't know that. I don't know that. But amid the craziness, there were also moments of incredible beauty. Like the story John told me from his first winter at the base about a former ammunition depot someone had turned into a house. And suddenly one day when I passed it, you heard the most beautiful piano kind of playing Chopin. And then you went into this building and in this huge room, there was this little tent.
他是怎么弄到一头熊的？我不知道。我不知道这个。我不知道这个。但在疯狂之中，也有令人难以置信的美丽时刻。就像约翰给我讲他在基地的第一个冬天的故事，关于某人把一座前军火库改造成的一座房子。突然有一天，当我路过那里时，你听到了最美妙的钢琴声，在弹奏肖邦。然后你走进了这栋建筑，在这个巨大的房间里，有一个小帐篷。
And inside the tent, you could see kind of the silhouette of a grand piano. And I looked in, and here was this kind of very refined, artistic guy sitting and playing beautifully on the piano. You never forget that stuff, right? The individual freedom on offer in Christiania attracted people from around the world, but there were other advantages
在帐篷里面，你可以看到一架三角钢琴的剪影。我往里看，这里坐着一个非常精致、富有艺术气息的家伙，正在优美地弹奏着钢琴。你永远不会忘记那种东西，对吧？克里斯蒂安尼亚所提供的个人自由吸引了来自世界各地的人们，但它还有其他优势
too, like how it had its own way of settling disputes and making collective decisions. Well, what appealed about it to me would be like every opinion gets heard and respected a lot. Mario Sierrasco moved to Christiania from Boston in the early 1980s, a little after John and Olay. And he says one of the big things he appreciated about the community was its particular decision-making process. By that point, the commune had roughly 1,000 residents,
，比如它有自己解决纠纷和做出集体决定的独特方式。嗯，它吸引我的地方在于，每一个意见都能得到倾听和高度尊重。马里奥·谢拉斯科（Mario Sierrasco）在20世纪80年代初从波士顿搬到了克里斯蒂安尼亚，比约翰和奥勒稍晚一些。他说，他非常欣赏这个社区的一点是其独特的决策过程。到了那个时候，公社大约有1000名居民，
large for a commune, but small for a democracy. And they took advantage of their size by adopting what's called a consensus system. We try to reach an agreement that everybody's satisfied with, which means if we're 100 people and 10 of those 100 people disagree, then we cannot pass this agreement. Well, but I'm just wondering, like, you've got a community of 800 or so people who, you know, might have very strong opinions about how the world should work, how the community should be run. It seems like it would be next to impossible to get
对公社来说规模很大，但对民主制来说规模很小。他们通过采用所谓的共识制度来利用他们的规模优势。我们试图达成一个人人满意的协议，这意味着如果我们有100人，其中10人不同意，那么我们就无法通过这个协议。嗯，但我在想，比如，你有一个由800人左右组成的社区，你知道的，他们对世界应该如何运转、社区应该如何管理可能会有强烈的意见。让每一个人对任何事情都达成一致，这似乎几乎是不可能的。那这怎么运作呢？你们怎么办？哦，它的运作方式是，好吧，看，我们再开个会吧。当然，你可能想知道丹麦当局对这个占领国家首都中心国 有土地的85英亩公社有何看法。在其成立后的十年里，哥本哈根警方曾多次试图驱逐占地者，但都遭到坚决抵抗。克里斯蒂安尼亚准备为把警察挡在门外而战，如有必要，将为生存而战。路障是用旧家具甚至是小船做成的。武器是鸡蛋，但当局
every single person to agree on anything. So how does that work? What do you do? Oh, it worked in the sense that, well, look, okay, let's have another meeting. Of course, you might be wondering what the Danish authorities thought of this 85-acre commune squatting on state property in the middle of the nation's capital. On several occasions in the decade following its founding, the Copenhagen police tried to remove the squatters, only to be met with determined resistance. Christiania is ready to fight to keep police out, and if necessary to fight for survival. The barricades are made of old furniture, even a boat. The weapons are eggs, but the authorities
心知肚明，任何企图消灭克里斯蒂安尼亚的举动都可能把哥本哈根变成欧洲又一个占地者战场。于是丹麦政府改变方针，决定容忍克里斯蒂安尼亚。当时的假设是，占地者最终会失去兴趣并自行离开，但当当局意识到这种情况不会发生时，已经太晚了。该地区太大了，人也太多了，因此将其清场的可能性变得既不可行，最终也不受欢迎。在大门之外，最初认为这只是一群懒惰、抽大麻的嬉皮士的看法
are only too aware that any attempt to get rid of Christiania could turn Copenhagen into another of Europe's squatter battlegrounds. So the Danish government changed course and decided to tolerate Christiania. The assumption was that the squatters would eventually lose interest and leave, but by the time the authorities realized that wasn't going to happen, it was too late. The area was too large and there were too many people, so the prospect of clearing them out became both untenable and eventually undesirable. Outside the gates, the initial perception that this was just a group of lazy pot-smoking hippies
正在改变，尤其是当丹麦电视台进行正面报道，描绘了公社日常生活的真实面貌之后。几十万游客每年蜂拥而至，来到丹麦首都中心的这座无政府主义公园。它的音乐场所开始举办从鲍勃·迪伦（Bob Dylan）到金属乐队（Metallica）等艺人的音乐会。
was changing, especially after favorable coverage on Danish television depicted what day-to-day life was actually like in the commune. Hundreds of thousands of tourists began flocking every year to the anarchist parkland in the center of the Danish capital. Its musical venues started hosting concerts featuring artists from Bob Dylan to Metallica.
尽管克里斯蒂安尼亚有着种种与丹麦其余地区截然不同的地方，但它已经成为一个既成事实，到20世纪80年代中期，它已成为哥本哈根标志性的一部分。今天的丹麦，一千多名嬉皮士以及他们的绵羊、山羊和狗庆祝了他们自己的城市的十周年。克里斯蒂安尼亚无政府主义公社实现了所有企业高管的梦想。
Despite everything that made it so different from the rest of Denmark, Christiania became a fact of life, and by the mid-1980s, an iconic part of Copenhagen. Denmark today, more than a thousand hippies and their sheep, goats, and dogs celebrated the 10th anniversary of their very own city. The anarchist commune of Christiania had achieved every corporate executive's dream.
它大到不能倒。但尽管取得了成功，居民们深知他们占领这片土地的法律地位依然很不稳定。克里斯蒂安尼亚仍然属于丹麦国防部。从法律上讲，克里斯蒂安尼亚随时可能被清空，驱逐占地者。所以我们总是有一种恐惧，害怕那个庞大的大家长突然醒来，你知道的，看到：“哦，他妈的里面在搞什么鬼？”你知道的，他们完全违抗了所有命令，你知道的。
It was too big to fail. But despite their successes, residents knew their legal status occupying this land continued to be tenuous. Christiania still belongs to the Danish Defense Ministry. At any time, legally, Christiania could be cleared of squatters. So we always had this fear about suddenly the big father waking up, you know, and seeing, oh, what the f*** goes on over there? You know, they totally disobey all the orders, you know.
我们去把这个地方清理干净吧。但他们知道这是一个社会的减压阀，他们知道要消灭一个童话故事是非常难的。所以他们从来没来过，对吧？他们从来没来过。不过慢慢地，随着时间推移，外部世界确实找上门来了。只是方式与约翰或任何早期居民预期的不同。从2000年代中期开始，一连串的问题迫使克里斯蒂安尼亚的居民重新思考他们最珍视的一些自由，并越来越依赖丹麦其他社会的帮助。
Let's go and clean up the place. But they knew that it was a valve for the society and they knew that it's very hard to kill a fairy tale. So they never came, right? They never came. Except that slowly, over time, the outside world did come for Christiania. Just not in the way John or any of the early residents expected. Starting in the mid-2000s, a cascade of problems forced Christiania's residents to rethink some of their most cherished freedoms and depend more and more on help from the rest of Danish society.
许多人担心，在这个过程中，这些变化使他们的反文化避难所变得越来越像丹麦的其他地方。嗯，你知道的，当然发生的事情是，这种毒品问题越来越多地渗入进来，这对克里斯蒂安尼亚产生了巨大的影响。克里斯蒂安尼亚的毒品市场被称为“推销员街”（Pusher Street），通常被认为是公社问题开始的地方。克里斯蒂安尼亚是丹麦唯一一个政府对吸毒睁一只眼闭一只眼的地方，公社最初允许任何类型的毒品被使用
And many worried the changes were making their counter-cultural haven more like the rest of Denmark in the process. Well, what, you know, of course, happened was that this drug thing crept in more and more and it had a gigantic impact on Christianity. The drug market in Christiania is known as Pusher Street, and it's often considered where the commune's problems began. Christiania was the only place in Denmark where the government turned a blind eye to drug use, and the commune initially allowed any type of drug to be used
并在公开场合销售。随后，在20世纪70年代末几名居民因海洛因过量死亡后，社区决定取缔硬性毒品，但继续允许大麻。奥勒和其他居民将此称为“垃圾封锁”（junk blockade）。这是一个他认为的黄金时代，在这个时期，推销员街几乎完全由住在克里斯蒂安尼亚的本地人控制，几乎就像一个日常农夫市集，只不过卖的是草。理想主义者想要获得优质的草和大麻树脂，并以公平的
and sold openly. Then, after several residents died from heroin overdoses in the late 1970s, the community decided to outlaw hard drugs, but continued to allow cannabis. Ole and other residents refer to this as the junk blockade. It's a period he sees as a kind of golden era, in which Pusher Street was almost entirely controlled by locals who lived in Christiania, almost like a daily farmers market, only for weed. Idealistic people wanting to get the good weed and the good hash and sell it at a fair
价格出售等等。所以在垃圾封锁之后，我们算是创造了一个完美的大麻市场。当我来到这里时，它，它是令人惊叹的。马里奥·谢拉斯科在垃圾封锁生效后的80年代在推销员街贩卖毒品，他描绘了类似的情景。作为推销员街，我们几乎是一个家庭。这是一个安全网。你知道的，我们几乎是一个家庭。这里有一个安全网。你知道的，这是一个非常文明的地方。
price and so on. So after the junk blockade, we had sort of created the perfect hash market. When I got here, it was, it was amazing. Mario Sierrasco sold drugs on Pusher Street in the 80s after the junk blockade went into effect and he paints a similar picture. As Pusher Street, we were a family almost. It was the safety net. You know, it were a family, almost. There was this safety net. You know, it was a really civilized place.
当时，像马里奥这样的毒贩认为他们最大的麻烦是警察。哥本哈根警方对克里斯蒂安尼亚的毒品文化心怀不满，经常违反政府与公社之间的非官方默契。他们对推销员街进行了有针对性的突袭，然后给当地毒贩判处轻刑，这只是一种大多具有象征意义的武力展示，并没有真正打乱生意。老兄，我们在刚开始卖大麻树脂的时候，
At the time, dealers like Marriott's thought their biggest problem was the cops. The Copenhagen police, resentful of Christiania's drug culture, often violated the government's unofficial understanding with the commune. They conducted targeted raids on Pusher Street and then slapped local dealers with light sentences, a mostly symbolic show of force that didn't actually disrupt business. Dude, when we sold hash in the beginning,
我们在那里站了一整天，赚得比出租车司机还少，还要冒着坐牢的风险，但刑期都很短。我坐过20天、40天、60天的牢。没关系，你知道的，这挺公平的。但最终人们发现，警察其实是克里斯蒂安尼亚最小的问题。更糟糕的是黑帮。由于大麻在丹麦是被禁的，货源必须来自海外，这通常意味着要与上游的国际犯罪组织打交道，比如地狱天使（Hells Angels），他们从阿富汗和摩洛哥等地进口。因此，自20世纪80年代以来，各种黑帮在推销员街断断续续地存在着。
we stood there all day, made less than a taxi driver and risked going to jail, but it was only small sentences. I've been in jail 20 days, 40 days, 60 days. It was okay, you know, it was fair enough. But eventually it became clear that the cops were the least of Christiania's problems. Far worse were the gangs. Since cannabis was prohibited in Denmark, the supply had to come from abroad, which often meant dealing with international criminal organizations up the chain, like the Hells Angels, who were importing from places like Afghanistan and Morocco. As a result, various gangs had an on-and-off presence on Pusher Street starting in the 1980s.
然后在大约2004年，一个新的保守派政府加重了大麻贩子的刑罚。更严厉的判刑吓退了推销员街的大多数本地人。这也推高了价格。黑帮趁虚而入，涌入这个利润丰厚的真空地带以夺取控制权。所以突然之间，你有了所有这些以前并没有什么权力的不同团伙。但他们意识到大麻市场里有很多钱，哇，这鬼东西太赚钱了。于是突然之间，那些总是带着刀子什么的黑帮，突然之间都有了枪。
Then around 2004, a new conservative government increased the penalties for cannabis dealers. The stiffer sentencing scared most of the locals away from Pusher Street. It also drove prices up. And into that lucrative vacuum, the gangs swept in to take control. So all of a sudden you have all these different groups that didn't really have any power before. But the hash market, they realized, wow, there's a lot of money in this s***. And so all of a sudden these gangs that were always there with knives and, you know, all of a sudden they had guns.
克里斯蒂安尼亚的居民对此几乎束手无策。毕竟，他们只是一群爱好和平的嬉皮士。在打击有组织犯罪时，他们根本没有胜算。没过多久，黑帮就开始为争夺推销员街的控制权而互相厮杀。问题是，每当两个帮派之间发生冲突，而帮派之间经常发生冲突时，推销员街就是他们选择进行谋杀的地方。奥勒可没有夸大其词。在过去的十年里，推销员街已成为臭名昭著的帮派暴力温床，包括殴打、持刀行刺、蒙面枪手在公共场所开枪以及一连串的枪击致死事件。
And there was almost nothing the residents of Christiania could do about it. After all, they were just a bunch of peace-loving hippies. They never really stood a chance fighting organized crime. And it wasn't long before the gangs began fighting each other for control over Pusher Street. Problem is whenever there's a trouble between two gangs and there are often are trouble between the gangs, Pusher Street is a place where they can choose to make the killings. And Ole is not exaggerating. In the past decade, Pusher Street has become a notorious hot spot for gang violence, including beatings, stabbings, masked gunmen opening fire in public, and a string of shooting deaths.
这发生在一场枪击案的两天后，当时在丹麦首都逮捕一名毒贩的行动中，两名警察和一名平民受伤。一名警察目前仍处于重伤状态。首都。一名警察目前仍处于重伤状态。如果你能概括一下，描述一下现在社区里的情绪。比如，大家都在说些什么？他们感觉如何？呃，我不知道。感觉我们处于某种政治边缘状态。现在我们只是在等待下一次谋杀或其他什么事情。
It comes two days after a shooting in which two police officers and a civilian were injured during an attempt to arrest a drug dealer in the Danish capital. One policeman is still in a serious condition. capital. One policeman is still in a serious condition. If you're able to generalize, describe kind of the mood in the community now. Like how, what are people saying? How are they feeling? Uh, I don't know. Feeling that we are in some sort of limbo. Now we are just waiting for maybe the next murder, whatever.
事情仍然失控。当我们回来时，公社居民最终决定对推销员街采取什么行动，以及这一决定对克里斯蒂安尼亚其余部分产生的连锁反应。我们与记者斯科特·古里安一起回来了。不久前我访问了克里斯蒂安尼亚，以更多地了解毒品贸易带来的余波。我第一次去那里时，并不是很确定会看到什么。我穿过这个狭窄的砖砌拱门进入社区，它立刻给人的感觉与哥本哈根几乎其他任何地方都不同。
Things are still out of control. When we come back, what the residents of the commune ultimately decided to do about Pusher Street and the ripple effects that decision has had on the rest of Christiania. We're back with reporter Scott Gurian. A while back I visited Christiania to learn more about the fallout from the drug trade. The first time I went there I wasn't quite sure what to expect. I walked through this narrow brick archway into the community, and it immediately felt different from almost everywhere else in Copenhagen.
这里没有汽车，几乎没有铺砌的道路，大多数建筑都喷满了涂鸦，还有写着诸如“清除你本地的法西斯”之类的政治涂鸦。我也清楚地意识到，我还没有完全领会这个地方到底有多大。除了森林和开阔的绿地，社区边缘还有这些巨大的山丘。它们是旧堡垒原始壁垒的遗迹。尽管这里身处大都市中心，但竟然有人养马。最终，我来到了推销员街。尽管这里身处大都市中心，但竟然有人养马。
There were no cars, few paved roads, and most of the buildings were covered with spray paint, along with political graffiti that said things like, delete your local fascist. It was also clear I hadn't fully comprehended just how big this place was. In addition to the forests and open green space, there were these giant hills around the edges of the community. They were the remains of the old fortress's original ramparts. Someone even had horses, despite this being in the middle of a metropolis. Eventually, I made my way to Pusher Street. Someone even had horses, despite this being in the middle of a metropolis.
最终，我来到了推销员街。这条街由一条通往中央广场的长巷组成，巷子两旁排满了出售大麻的合板摊位，完全是公开营业的。摊位上喷上了各个生意的名字，比如“糖果店”（Candy Shop）和“紫大猩猩”（Purple Gorilla）。这里挤满了看起来来自社会各阶层的顾客。多可爱啊？一克和一克半。如果你想要100的，你用500买一个。
Eventually, I made my way to Pusher Street. The street consisted of a long alleyway that led to a central plaza, and it was lined with these plywood stalls selling cannabis totally out in the open. They were spray painted with the names of each of the businesses, like Candy Shop and Purple Gorilla. It was brimming with customers who seemed to come from all walks of life. How sweet? One gram and one and a half grams. If you want 100, you get one for the 500.
如果我享受它，你就能稍微高兴一点。我能看看你的笑容吗？请让我看看你的笑容好吗？但尽管商业活动繁华，但很显然，奥勒和马里奥所描述的那种农夫市集氛围——那种你可以悠闲地查看货品并与毒贩友好交谈的地方——早已不复存在。现在所有的毒贩都是外来者，与克里斯蒂安尼亚并没有太多联系。
If I enjoy it, you can be a little bit happy. Can I see your smile? Can I please see your smile? But despite the bustle of commerce, it was clear the farmers market atmosphere described by Ole and Marius, that place where you could leisurely check out what was on offer and have a friendly chat with the dealers, was long gone. All of the dealers now were outsiders who didn't really have much of a connection to Christiania.
在我访问期间，警方加强了打击力度，部署了便衣警察，并一天几次出现抓人。因此，所有卖家都表现得疑神疑鬼，包括当我试图插进一些随意的提问时，我差不多完全失败了。这是什么曲奇？我有香草曲奇。哦，好吧。你自己做的？不，有位女士会顺路送来。不，没买没卖就问太多问题。不，我的意思是我得知道我买的是什么。好吧。
Around the time of my visit, the police had increased their crackdowns, deploying undercover cops and showing up several times a day to arrest people. As a result, all the sellers were acting skittish, including when I tried sprinkling in some casual questions, something at which I more or less totally failed. What kind of cookies are they? I have vanilla cookies. Oh, okay. You make them yourself? No, there's a lady that comes by. No, too much a question without buying, without selling. No, I mean, I want to know what I'm getting. Okay. There had been several signs at the entrance to the street warning people not to take photos, but there was this one tourist who either didn't see the signs or chose to ignore them, and he took a picture
街口有几个标牌警告人们不要拍照，但有一个游客要么没看到这些标牌，要么选择无视它们，他还是拍了张照片。
anyway. Immediately, some guy who was working for the gangs as a lookout person approached him and made him delete it off his phone. Don't you understand? He said, we're criminals. Ultimately, the whole scene felt antithetical to the spirit in which Christiania was founded. Many Christiania residents, including Marius and Ole, have always fervently believed that the best way to fix the problems on Pusher Street would be to legalize cannabis in Denmark. Legalization would take power away from the gangs. But so far, that's something Denmark's federal government has been unwilling to do.
立刻，一个为黑帮当望风人的家伙走近他，让他从手机里删掉照片。你听不懂吗？他说，我们是罪犯。最终，整个场景让人感觉与克里斯蒂安尼亚创立的精神背道而驰。许多克里斯蒂安尼亚居民，包括马里奥和奥勒，一直热切地相信，解决推销员街问题的最佳方法是在丹麦将大麻合法化。合法化将把权力从黑帮手中夺走。但到目前为止，这是丹麦联邦政府一直不愿意做的事情。
So Ole and several others decided they had no choice but to change one of the fundamental things that made Christiania different in the first place. In the absence of legalization, they wanted to ban all drug sales in the community. Over the last three years, we have had three killings in Pusher Street, so we got fed up. We couldn't talk to the people, we didn't know the people. We knew that you had all these gangs like Hells Angels running the show, making the money. So, there was nothing in it anymore for Christianity, for anybody in Christianity. So we don't want that anymore.
所以奥勒和其他几个人决定，他们别无选择，只能改变使克里斯蒂安尼亚与众不同的根本因素之一。在缺乏合法化的情况下，他们希望禁止社区内所有毒品的销售。在过去三年里，我们在推销员街发生了三起谋杀案，所以我们受够了。我们无法与这些人对话，我们不认识这些人。我们知道你所有的黑帮，比如地狱天使在操纵一切、赚取金钱。所以，这对克里斯蒂安尼亚、对克里斯蒂安尼亚的任何人来说，已经没有任何利益可言了。所以我们再也不要这样了。
And in the summer of 2023, before the consensus process could even come to a decision, a group of residents who were fed up with Pusher Street decided to take matters into their own hands. On the early morning of August 8th, a bunch of residents of Christiania went out and blocked off Pusher Street. Yeah, I was part of that. You were? Why did you do that? To show that we don't want it. Actually, to block it, if we could. What was that like? It was such a relief.
2023年夏天，甚至在共识程序得出决定之前，一群受够了推销员街的居民决定自己动手解决问题。8月8日清晨，克里斯蒂安尼亚的一群居民走出去，封锁了推销员街。是的，我是其中的一员。你是？你为什么要这么做？为了表明我们不想要它。实际上，如果可以的话，就是把它封锁起来。那感觉是怎样的？这真是一种解脱。
Olli described to me how they used heavy machinery to barricade the entrances with shipping containers and concrete blocks on either side of the street, making it impossible for people to enter. And then, sort of of we left it. The pushers came back eight o'clock in the morning. And they were angry. And they were very angry.
奥勒向我描述了他们如何使用重型机械在街道两侧用海运集装箱和混凝土块设置路障，使人们无法进入。然后，我们就把它留在那儿了。推销贩子早上八点钟就回来了。他们很生气。他们非常生气。
And like ten o'clock, they actually managed to find a way to move the containers. So at twelve o'clock, everything was open again. Were you expecting that the blockade would last longer? I expected it to last a little longer, yes. But I didn't expect it to really last. Because if they had not managed to move the containers and reopen Pusher Street, you would have had a lot of trouble. They would have sought revenge.
大约十点钟，他们竟然设法找到了移动集装箱的方法。所以在十二点钟，一切又都重新开放了。你原本预料封锁能持续更长时间吗？我确实预料它能持续更长时间。但我并没有指望它真的能持久。因为如果他们没有设法移动集装箱并重新开放推销员街，你就会遇到大麻烦。他们会寻求报复。
The reality is that the only action the unarmed people of Christiania could ever take against the gangs was purely symbolic. Not only had the action not been agreed on by the larger community in a consensus meeting, but the residents also knew that simply saying that they wanted to close Pusher Street wouldn't make a difference. Faced with a ban, the dealers would just refuse to leave. Which is why some of the residents wanted to reverse another long-standing tradition. If the community finally agreed to close Pusher Street, they also wanted to issue a public statement saying that they were powerless to do it on their own, essentially inviting the police to come in and enforce
现实情况是，克里斯蒂安尼亚手无寸铁的人民对黑帮能采取的唯一行动纯粹是象征性的。这一行动不仅没有得到更大社区在共识会议上的同意，而且居民们也知道，仅仅声称他们想关闭推销员街并不能改变什么。面对禁令，毒贩只会拒绝离开。这就是为什么一些居民想要推翻另一个长期存在的传统。如果社区最终同意关闭推销员街凭一己之力无能为力，他们还想发表公开声明，基本上是邀请警察进来替他们执行
the closure for them. The irony of which was not lost on anyone. The commune's residents had spent their lives trying to live without the state and state violence as an organizing force. But now, if they wanted to finally kick the gangs out, the anarchists of Christiania would have to ask the state for help. So somehow the police, they won. You have all the gangs, but police is certainly the strongest gang.
关闭。其中的讽刺意味每个人都心知肚明。公社居民一生都在努力在没有国家和国家暴力作为组织力量的情况下生活。但现在，如果他们想彻底赶走黑帮，克里斯蒂安尼亚的无政府主义者就不得不向国家寻求帮助。所以不知何故，警察赢了。你拥有所有的黑帮，但警察无疑是最强大的黑帮。
Have things changed where the communities had like recent conversations with the police and with the city where you feel like you can trust them now more than in the past? No. We have talks, but you know personally I don't trust them. No. So how does the community then feel about issuing this statement saying we're like inviting the police to help us out? Yeah, that was really a strange feeling. After the latest spike in violence, and not long after the Night of the Barricades, hundreds of Christianites came to a hastily called meeting
情况变了吗？社区最近是否与警方和市政府进行过对话，让你觉得现在比过去更能信任他们了？没有。我们有对话，但你知道，就我个人而言，我不信任他们。没有。那么社区对于发表这份声明说我们就像是邀请警察来帮助我们作何感想？是的，那真是一种奇怪的感觉。在最新一波暴力事件激增之后，就在路障之夜后不久，数百名克里斯蒂安尼亚人赶来参加了一场仓促召集的会议，
in the Gray Hall, this large concert venue they often use for important gatherings. And then we had a half an hour that was very special where people just came up to the microphone, they didn't make any speeches, they just said, like, I want to close Bursa Street, I want to close Bursa Street. And that was somehow so convincing to the minority who didn't want that.
地点在灰厅（Gray Hall），这是他们经常用于重要聚会的大型音乐厅。然后我们有半小时非常特殊的时刻，人们只是走到麦克风前，他们不发表任何演讲，他们只是说，比如，我想关闭推销员街，我想关闭推销员街。这不知何故对那些不想这样的小少数人产生了极大的说服力。
So that was the end of the meeting. To hear Ole tell it, the consensus process did what it was supposed to do. It created consensus. But some residents paint a different picture. They say the consensus system is just the next tradition of Christianias that has begun to fall apart. Christiania is not in agreement about this at all. Not long after the decision, I ran into Mario Sierrasco outside an event on cannabis legalization,
会议就这样结束了。在奥勒看来，共识机制发挥了它的作用。它达成了共识。但一些居民描绘了不同的画面。他们说共识制度只是克里斯蒂安尼亚开始崩塌的又一个传统。克里斯蒂安尼亚对此根本没有达成一致。就在决定做出后不久，我在一场关于大麻合法化的活动外遇到了马里奥·谢拉斯科，
which remember was still his desired outcome. He told me that he thought closing the street wasn't the solution, and he said the decision was far from unanimous. I don't want to push the street closed. It's a part of the freedom that appealed to me about Christianity. But there's a small group of people in Christianity, they're hijacking the meetings. I would say there's about 50 people out of the 900 people
请记住，这仍然是他期望的结果。他告诉我，他认为关闭这条街并不是解决办法，并表示这一决定远未达到全票通过。我不想推动关闭推销员街。这是吸引我来到克里斯蒂安尼亚的自由的一部分。但克里斯蒂安尼亚有一小群人，他们在劫持会议。我想说，在我们总共900人中，大约有50人
that we are out there doing this. And they're very active, they go to every meeting and they just force their agenda through. So when you say this group of 50 people or whatever has kind of hijacked the process, is this kind of like a failure of the consensus process? They have smashed the consensus process. At the meeting, they actually got in a circle
在外面做这件事。他们非常活跃，他们参加每一次会议，只是强行推行他们的议程。所以当你说是这50个人左右的群体劫持了这一过程时，这算是一种共识机制的失败吗？他们已经砸碎了共识机制。在会议上，他们实际上围成了一个圈，
and went up to the microphone one by one. Yes, I want to close Pusha Street. Then the next one comes up. Yes, I want to close Pusha Street. And they're just in a circle, a nonstop circle. And every time anybody else tried to say something, they were booed at. Marius and Ole had different recollections
一个接一个地走到麦克风前。是的，我想关闭推销员街。然后下一个上来。是的，我想关闭推销员街。他们只是围成一个圈，一个不停歇的圈。每当其他人试图说点什么时，他们就会遭到嘘声。马里奥和奥勒对
about whether the majority of attendees were in favor of closing the street or keeping it open. But Ole did agree about one thing. When you say it was so convincing to them, they changed their mind in the end? They didn't change their mind. They just gave up. Okay.
大多数出席者是赞成关闭街道还是保持开放有不同的回忆。但奥勒在一件事上确实意见一致。当你说是对他们很有说服力时，他们最后改变了主意？他们没有改变主意。他们只是放弃了。好吧。
So is that, I mean, I'm not an expert on how consensus is supposed to work, but is, I mean, like generally consensus, is everyone supposed to agree or how does it? Yeah, that's, you know, it's not really a fair system. You know? And so, on a Saturday morning last April... Surrounded by media from around the world, residents of Christiania gathered for a ceremony where they dug up the cobblestones of Pusher Street to evict the Pusher's once and for all. Christiania's marching band even showed up
所以那是，我的意思是，我不是共识应该如何运作的专家，但是，我的意思是，通常来说共识，是不是每个人都应该同意，还是说它怎么运作？是的，那是，你知道的，这其实不是一个公平的系统。你知道吗？因此，在去年四月的一个星期六早晨……在世界各地媒体的包围下，克里斯蒂安尼亚的居民聚集在一起举行了一场仪式，他们掘开了推销员街的鹅卵石，要一劳永逸地驱逐推销贩子。克里斯蒂安尼亚的军乐队甚至也出场
to participate in the festivities. Copenhagen's Lord Mayor, Sophie Andersen, who grew up attending concerts in Christiania, was also there doing rounds of media interviews. We cannot have a Christiania that is dying out because people don't dare to be here. Pusher Street has to die in order for Christiania to live. Are you going to take a cobblestone as a souvenir?
来参与这一盛事。在克里斯蒂安尼亚听着音乐会长大的哥本哈根市长索菲·安德森（Sophie Andersen）也出席了活动，并接受了一轮又一轮的媒体采访。我们不能让一个正在消亡的克里斯蒂安尼亚存在，因为人们不敢留在这里。推销员街必须消亡，克里斯蒂安尼亚才能生存。你要拿一块鹅卵石作为纪念品吗？
I am truly going to take a cobblestone as a souvenir, and I'm going to place it next to the cobblestone from the Berlin Wall. Marius, for his part, was decidedly not celebrating. He said he found the festivities downright depressing. It seems to me out of control, I don't know, this sort of gray zone that we're in now politically. Because before we said, f*** you to the state, we're doing things our way.
我真的要拿一块鹅卵石作为纪念品，我要把它放在柏林墙鹅卵石的旁边。就马里奥而言，他绝对没有在庆祝。他说他发现这些庆祝活动简直令人沮丧。在我看来，这已经失控了，我不知道，这是我们现在在政治上所处的这种灰色地带。因为以前我们对国家竖起中指，我们按自己的方式做事。
But now we're in their pocket. In their pocket, because even as most of the recent attention has been focused on Pusher Street, Christiania has struck another deal with the government that could integrate the commune with the city even more. Not by kicking people out, but by bringing people from the outside in. Denmark is struggling with an affordable housing crisis. And from the government's perspective, Christiania's undeveloped land, so close to the center of the city, is ripe for development.
但现在我们落入了他们的掌心。落入了他们的掌心，因为尽管最近大部分注意力都集中在推销员街上，但克里斯蒂安尼亚又与政府达成了一项协议，这可能会使该公社更进一步地融入城市。不是通过赶走人们，而是通过把外面的人引入进来。丹麦正在与经济适用房危机作斗争。从政府的角度来看，克里斯蒂安尼亚未开发的土地距离市中心如此之近，正是开发的成熟时机。
But from Christiania's perspective, this new logic has rekindled the residents' fears of being evicted from their homes, which, remember, they do not own. So, a few years ago, Christiania and the Danish government struck a bargain. The state will allow for the community to own its land outright by purchasing it far below market value. But in return, over the next few years, Christiania will have to build government-subsidized low-income apartments for 300 new people. Which you might think should solve the problem. Christiani has always branded itself as a place for the adrift and downtrodden. So how could it possibly say no to low-income housing?
但从克里斯蒂安尼亚的角度来看，这种新逻辑重新点燃了居民们对被驱逐出家园的恐惧，记住，这些家园并不属于他们。因此，几年前，克里斯蒂安尼亚与丹麦政府达成了一项协议。国家允许该社区通过以远低于市场价的价格购买土地来彻底拥有它。但作为回报，在接下来的几年里，克里斯蒂安尼亚必须为 300 名新居民建造政府补贴的低收入公寓。你可能会认为这应该能解决问题。克里斯蒂安尼亚一直将自己标榜为漂泊者和受压迫者的庇护所。那么它怎么可能对低收入住房说不呢？
But in reality, the deal remains highly controversial among the residents. Proving that even anarchists can go nimby. I know there's been a lot of opposition to the plan to build public housing, but I'm wondering if you've heard anyone express that the community should be welcoming to people living in public housing because they seem to be exactly the type of people the community has always accepted in the past. I don't have a problem with the people. I have a problem with the amount of people
但现实中，这项协议在居民中仍然极具争议。这证明了即使是无政府主义者也会有邻避情结。我知道各界对建设公共住房的计划有很多反对意见，但我很好奇，你是否听到有人表达过这样的观点：社区应该对住在公共住房里的人表示欢迎，因为他们似乎正是社区过去一向接纳的那类人。我对这些人没有意见。我对人数有意见
and I have a problem especially with the volume of new buildings. That's where I have my problem. Adam Suellentrop Ollie Luke Anderson likens the plan to a Trojan horse that will ultimately destroy Christiania. The government's plan will increase the population by a third and radically alter the geography of the area. The way he puts it, the housing plan would be the equivalent of the area. The way he puts it, the housing plan would be the equivalent of plopping down a thousand shipping containers in the middle of the community. Plus, you can't imagine how the commune will be able to work within
而且我对新建筑的数量尤其有意见。这就是我的问题所在。亚当·苏伦特罗普（Adam Suellentrop）奥利·卢克·安德森（Ollie Luke Anderson）将该计划比作特洛伊木马，最终将摧毁克里斯蒂安尼亚。政府的计划将使人口增加三分之一，并从根本上改变该地区的地理面貌。用他的话来说，这个住房计划就相当于。用他的话来说，住房计划的效果等同于。在社区中间空投一千个集市箱。另外，你无法想象公社将如何运作
the government's public housing bureaucracy. It will be very hard to combine the way we do stuff in Christiania with the way people do it in social housing projects. It will not really be part of the rest of Christiania. We'll get like two Christianias. On this issue, Marius agrees with Ole. He sees both the closing of Pusher Street and the building of the affordable housing as part of the same worrying trend toward normalcy and even gentrification. That Christiania's new residents will water down
政府的公共住房官僚体系。要把我们在克里斯蒂安尼亚做事的方式与人们在社会住房项目中做事的方式结合起来，将会非常困难。它不会真正成为其余克里斯蒂安尼亚的一部分。我们会得到两个克里斯蒂安尼亚。在这个问题上，马里乌斯（Marius）同意奥利的看法。他认为关闭普舍尔街和建设保障性住房都是向正常化甚至高档化发展的同一个令人担忧的趋势的一部分。克里斯蒂安尼亚的新居民将会冲淡
precisely what drew him to the community in the first place. 300 more boring people in here, or 300 more families in here not really interested in Christianity. They just want the location. And as soon as all these people move in, they're going to start complaining about the noise. Oh, the music is too loud, and then your lawn is a bit too dirty. And you know, just more and more control is going to come. And we're going to end up like everywhere else.
正是这一点最初吸引他来到这个社区。这里多了 300 个无聊的人，或者这里多了 300 个对基督教不感兴趣的家庭。他们只是想要这个地段。一旦所有这些人搬进来，他们就会开始抱怨噪音。哦，音乐太大了，然后你的草坪有点太脏了。你知道，越来越多的控制将会到来。我们将最终变得和别处一样。
For Marius, the community's counterculture, just like its consensus process and its tolerance towards cannabis, is one of the pillars of Christiania. And he thinks it is the next to crumble. I don't know. You know, I'm going to continue. I'm going to continue painting and selling my art, but it'll feel maybe ironic to be a rebel in the middle
对马里乌斯来说，社区的反文化，正如其共识进程和对大麻的宽容一样，是克里斯蒂安尼亚的支柱之一。他认为这是下一个崩溃的支柱。我不知道。你知道，我会继续。我会继续画画和卖我的艺术品，但在中间当一个叛逆者可能会觉得有点讽刺
of something that is totally commercial. If they start having, you know, sort of fancy wine bars and souvenir shops, then I will start thinking where to go to find freedom again. But some residents are cautiously optimistic that there might actually be a way to make this work without sacrificing everything that's special about Christiania. So in this area we have pointed out that we could place two buildings. Meta Prague has lived in Christiania for nearly 40 years. And toward the end of my visit, she gave me a tour of some of the proposed
一个完全商业化的环境。如果他们开始有，你知道，那种高档的酒吧和纪念品商店，那么我就会开始考虑去哪里寻找自由。但一些居民持谨慎乐观态度，认为确实有一种方法可以在不牺牲克里斯蒂安尼亚特有的一切的情况下实现这一目标。因此，在这个区域，我们指出了我们可以放置两座建筑物的地方。梅塔·布拉格（Meta Prague）在克里斯蒂安尼亚生活了近 40 年。在我的访问即将结束时，她带我参观了一些提议的
sites for the new housing. At the moment it's an open space where we have storage for woods and some very beautiful trees. And on the other side they have a nice garden for this huge building over there. They have a public garden. So a lot of this would be demolished to make way for the housing. Mette has a background in architecture and urban renewal, and lately she's been using her experience to help the community negotiate the terms of its housing agreement with the
新住房的地点。目前它是一个开放的空间，我们有木材储存库和一些非常美丽的树木。在另一边，他们为那边的那栋巨大建筑有一个不错的花园。他们有一个公共花园。因此，为了给住房腾出空间，这里的很大一部分将被拆除。梅塔有建筑学和城市更新的背景，最近她一直在利用自己的经验帮助社区与
Danish government. One of the challenges, Meta explains, is that for a long time now, Christiania has had a specific process to carefully vet new people before they move into the neighborhood. Nowadays, when we have an empty house and invite people to apply for it, we are free to choose who will come and live here, to choose outcasts, spacey thinking people who will fit to the house best. For example, what could this person give back to the community? Are they a good carpenter? Are they a skilled gardener who will take care of the neighborhood's green spaces?
丹麦政府。梅塔解释说，其中一个挑战是，长期以来，克里斯蒂安尼亚一直有一个特定的流程，在新人搬进社区之前对他们进行仔细审查。如今，当我们有一栋空房子并邀请人们申请时，我们可以自由选择谁来这里生活，挑选那些最适合这栋房子的局外人、思想空灵的人。例如，这个人能为社区回馈什么？他们是一个好的木匠吗？他们是熟练的园丁，会照顾社区的绿地吗？
Maybe they're good at planning meetings and events. With people applying for public housing, those factors would no longer matter. Still, Mette says there are creative loopholes the community can use to navigate this new bureaucratic system, and she's ready to deal with the challenge head-on. I think you just have to face it that it will, that Christianity will change with new inhabitants. And the question is, do Christians need new inhabitants? Or can we go on like we are today? And basically I think that in all communities, you need to always be developing. So you always have to be in a kind of dialogue with the outside, inside, outside, inside,
也许他们擅长策划会议和活动。对于申请公共住房的人来说，这些因素将不再重要。不过，梅塔表示，社区可以利用创造性的漏洞来驾驭这个新的官僚系统，她已经准备好迎接这个挑战。我想你不得不面对这样一个事实，那就是它会，克里斯蒂安尼亚会随着新居民的到来而改变。问题是，克里斯蒂安尼亚需要新居民吗？还是我们可以像今天这样继续下去？基本上我认为，在所有的社区里，你总是需要发展的。所以你必须总是与外部、内部、外部、内部保持某种对话，
because otherwise you will slowly die. Despite some of the opposition to the new housing, this was another sentiment I heard a lot, that change itself isn't inherently something to be afraid of. Christiania cannot end up as a hippie museum, kind of, right? John Bang Carlson no longer lives in Christiania, but he agrees with Meta Prague. He believes that the only real mistake is not changing. If the buildings where ordinary people can come in, old people, young people, lonely mothers,
因为否则你就会慢慢死去。尽管有人反对新住房，但这是我听到的另一种普遍情绪，即改变本身并不是一件可怕的事情。克里斯蒂安尼亚不能最终变成一个嬉皮士博物馆，对吧？约翰·邦·卡尔森（John Bang Carlson）不再住在克里斯蒂安尼亚，但他同意梅塔·布拉格的看法。他认为唯一的真正错误就是不改变。如果普通人可以进来的建筑物，老人，年轻人，孤独的母亲，
I think that Christianity should trust in the strengths of its own spirit to a degree that they're not afraid of being wiped out by incoming people. It should develop with the surrounding society. The truth is, for all of Christianity's efforts to exist separate and apart from the world, this place has never really been able to be as completely independent as its founders
我认为克里斯蒂安尼亚应该在一定程度上相信自己精神的力量，不害怕被新来的人消灭。它应该随着周围社会的发展而发展。事实是，尽管克里斯蒂安尼亚做出了所有努力，试图与世界分离开来，但这个地方从来没有真正能够像其创始人当年设想的那样完全独立。
had envisioned all those years ago. I ran this by John and Ole, and they were quick to agree. Of course, it has been a grand illusion to think that Christiania at any point was separated from the world. Christiania is very much a normal part of Denmark. It's still a bit different as a neighborhood, but it's part of the rest. Christianity will even have to take out a bank loan
我把这件事告诉了约翰和奥利，他们很快表示赞同。当然，认为克里斯蒂安尼亚在任何时候都与世隔绝，这只是一个宏大的幻想。克里斯蒂安尼亚在很大程度上是丹麦正常的一部分。作为一个街区，它仍然有点不同，但它是其余部分的一部分。克里斯蒂安尼亚甚至不得不向银行贷款
to buy the land and build the new housing. They'll make their money back by charging the new tenants rent. Things like interest rates, inflation, and the real estate market. These things now matter just as much within the walls of Christiania as anywhere else in the EU. In the end, it's clear that the world's problems have also become Christiania's problems.
来买地建新房。他们将通过向新租户收取租金来收回成本。诸如利率、通货膨胀和房地产市场之类的事情。如今，这些事情在克里斯蒂安尼亚围墙内的重要性与欧盟其他任何地方一样。最后，很明显，世界的问题也成为了克里斯蒂安尼亚的问题。
But John says that even if the community can't totally escape from all the different pressures, that doesn't make it any less of an achievement. So if Christianity were to close tomorrow, would you look back at it and think it's been a success? Certainly. I certainly would. I certainly would. I think Christianity's impact, apart from being a beautiful urban flower that you are
但约翰说，即使社区无法完全摆脱所有不同的压力，这也不意味着它不失为一项伟大的成就。因此，如果克里斯蒂安尼亚明天就要关闭，你回首过往，会认为它是一次成功吗？当然。我当然会。我当然会。我认为克里斯蒂安尼亚的影响，除了是一朵美丽的城市之花，让你
entertained by and like the smell of, it's that all of us have the power, if we are courageous enough, to create our own surroundings. That we can decide our own way of living. We can actually kick down the walls to get out in the open air and at least try to do it, right? 99% of BizzBull was reported this week by Scott Gurion, edited by Joe Rosenberg, with additional reporting by Kim Hansen, Naomi Fowler, and Polly Boe. Mixed by Hazik Bin Ahmad Farid. Music by Swan Real.
感到愉悦并喜欢它的气味之外，还在于我们所有人都有力量，只要我们足够勇敢，去创造我们自己的周围环境。我们可以决定我们自己的生活方式。我们实际上可以踢倒围墙走到开阔的空气中，至少尝试去做，对吧？本周，Scott Gurion 报道了 99% 的 BizzBull，Joe Rosenberg 编辑，Kim Hansen、Naomi Fowler 和 Polly Boe 进行了补充报道。Hazik Bin Ahmad Farid 混音。音乐由 Swan Real 提供。
Fact checking by Sona Avakian. If you want to learn more about Christiania and hear other fascinating stories from around the world, be sure to check out Scott's own podcast, Far From Home. Scott has been reporting for decades from places like Iran and Mongolia and Chernobyl, and he puts all that experience into his show. Far From Home is about to launch its fourth season, and I can't recommend it enough. Go subscribe now. So, as a thanks this week to Ulla Mortensen and to criminologist David Sostel at the University
Sona Avakian 进行事实核查。如果你想更多地了解克里斯蒂安尼亚并听取来自世界各地的其他精彩故事，请务必查看 Scott 自己的播客《远离家乡》（Far From Home）。几十年来，Scott 一直在伊朗、蒙古和切尔诺贝利等地进行报道，他将所有这些经验都倾注到了他的节目中。《远离家乡》即将推出第四季，我极力推荐。现在就去订阅吧。因此，作为本周对 Ulla Mortensen 以及瑞典隆德大学犯罪学家 David Sostel 的感谢，
of Lund in Sweden, who was a huge help with this story but whose voice we didn't get to include. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Dulemi Hall is our senior editor, Taylor Shedrick is our intern. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashma Dawn, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potuck, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
他在这个故事中提供了巨大的帮助，但我们没能收录他的声音。Cathy Tu 是我们的执行制片人，Kurt Kolstad 是数字总监，Dulemi Hall 是我们的资深编辑，Taylor Shedrick 是我们的实习生。团队的其他成员包括 Chris Berube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Vivian Leigh、Lashma Dawn、Gabbriella Gladney、Kelly Prime、Jacob Maldonado-Medina、Nina Potuck 和我 Roman Mars。99% visible 标志由 Stefan Lawrence 创建。
We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California, home of the Oakland Roots soccer club, of which I'm a proud community owner. Other teams may come and go, but the roots are Oakland first, always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new discord server, where we talk about the power broker. We talk about episodes.
我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北面六个街区，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的潘多拉大楼里，这里是奥克兰根足球俱乐部的所在地，我很荣幸能成为该俱乐部的社区老板。其他球队可能会来来去去，但根基永远是奥克兰第一。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们的新 discord 服务器，我们在那里谈论权力掮客。我们谈论剧集。
We talk about architecture. We talk about flags, talk about all kinds of things. There's a link to that Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们谈论建筑。我们谈论旗帜，谈论各种各样的事情。在 99PI.org 上有一个指向该 Discord 服务器以及 99PI 过去每集节目的链接。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。